hey youtubers it's Charlie really big
Jessie quick season 3 news in a really
big mind trip story about Jay Garrick
preseason one on the flash I'm going to
start with the history stuff then i'll
talk about Jessie quick there was
another heroes and villains fan fest
over the weekend so the cast of arrow
flashed the CW shows were there and we
learned a couple really cool
behind-the-scenes facts as well as some
stuff that's happening on the set
especially the flash so just to start
with the flash back story stuff you know
really cool stuff from before they were
making the pilot Rick his net who was
Eddie Thawne was there he did a panel
and he explained that when he was
auditioning for his role it actually
said Jay Garrick like he was originally
supposed to be Jay Garrick on the TV
show but before the pilot phase he
became Eddie Thawne they tied him to the
ER thon character in the rest is history
so like he wasn't going to be Jay
Garrick after he became Eddie Thawne but
I just think it's funny when you
remember what happened during season two
how that all played out obviously they
brought in Teddy Sears they did the
hunter zolomon zoom arc I don't know if
they were originally intending for you
know what ended up happening with those
big args when they were making the pilot
I think they had a vague idea they knew
they'd work Jay Garrick in some way but
I don't know that they necessarily had
already worked out the big zoom twist
those types of things usually don't get
decided to like the break after each
season finishes when they start pitching
ideas for the next season so on top of
that Caitlin snow was originally
supposed to be an older character a love
interest for Harrison wells they were
still going to do the big Harrison wells
eobard thawne twist but originally like
the Caitlin snow character was going to
be more of like a Tina McGee slightly
older have more parity with Harrison
wells they were still gonna do the dead
lover Allah firestorm like Ronnie
Raymond had been killed she thought he
was dead for most of season one but
instead of firestorm he was originally
going to be the mist the Kyle Nimbus
character that they ended up using i
think was like episode 3 and Harley
rathaway the Pied Piper character was
going to be on Team flash but it doesn't
specify if it was going to be Pied Piper
instead of Cisco or in addition to Cisco
so you can see how a lot of times things
will change during the pilot phase when
they're writing that pilot script all
that changed when they shot it like when
they
not the pilot they shot at with Cisco
with the firestorm twist with rick has
net being Eddie Thawne secretly the
ancestor of EO bar dawn and then I think
at that point they had decided to work
in a John Wesley Shipp jay garrick twist
but it might not have been completely
explicit they might have been like okay
we know we want to do John Wesley Shipp
Jay Garrick which is under exactly how
we're gonna do it we're gonna wait till
season two to figure it out you have to
remember that this was all before season
what happened before they ever shot that
first episode so in retrospect I'm
actually pretty happy with the way
things went down they could still
totally bring Eddie back as a twist on a
new speedster like cobalt blue or
something they always mix and match
things from the comics with the
characters on a TV show so I think they
found that nice balance where they can
do just as many crazy things as they can
think of it rope it into flash
continuity just because the flash comics
have been so crazy they're very
accommodating in that way speaking of
which we have like the big rogues vs.
rogues war that's going to be happening
this season that's just an example of
how many awesome characters they have
there's so many obscure characters that
they could pull out and do awesome
versions of on the TV show that I was
kind of joking the other day that I
would like to see them reform the TV
Suicide Squad with defeated flash
roguelike have a version of The Suicide
Squad that's destro killer frost
peekaboo maybe Huntress Stephen Amell
who was also at this big convention was
also saying like if he had his pick of
the litter in terms of new characters to
bring on a team arrow he was like
Deathstroke in Huntress I would love for
them to be on team arrow but no idea if
they're ever going to get to do that
just because they had that big ben
affleck destro teaser this morning so it
seems like he's going to be a big movie
character so with Manu Bennett being a
series regular on another TV series you
know his schedule pry is going to work
out too good the movie stuff doesn't
help so I'm not expecting Deathstroke to
come back anytime soon but the other
really big thing so this is actually
maybe even bigger deal but I think we
were all expecting it to happen there
were people on the set of the flash the
other week they said they saw Jesse
quick in her comic book costume but
obviously because there's no special
effects there was no context we have no
idea whether or not she will actually
have speed force powers only that she
will be wearing a very common
Liberty Bell Jessie quick type costume
so because they're still filming like
the first block of episodes that means
that we'll see Jessie quick in that
crazy comic-book costume in the first
like five or six episodes they might not
even be filming episode 6 it might be by
episode 4 so we won't have to wait that
long to see some really awesome Jessie
quick deep cuts from the comics but for
those of you asking i know i've talked
about killer frost a little bit i've
been meaning to do a killer frost video
we will totally see her come back in
some way this season you know some comic
booky twist on it the earth to version
of her was dead but because flashpoint
it's all up in the air so she could come
from Earth one she could come from
earth-2 but danielle panabaker Caitlin's
like our earth one caitlin snow is still
on team flash you might have missed her
but in that very first trailer they
posted a comic con she's here in the
background treating Wally while he's on
the gurney with the rest of them
standing around so whatever is happening
with team flash in season 3 caitlin snow
starts on the team but they haven't said
much about how her personality is going
to change i'm actually really curious to
see if she's more like season 1 Caitlyn
where she's a little bit colder or if
she's a little joke here just remains to
be seen but yes killer frost will
totally be back so let me know in the
comments when do you think that we will
actually see Jessie quick in a comic
book costume not speed for sports a
comic book costume because a lot of
times they'll just have outfits that are
teasing comic book costumes like Wally's
car was painted to look like a flash
costume so that might be how we get
reintroduced to Jessie quick like she
just wears very comic booky costumes
then we actually see her get speed force
powers but usually when they do
introduce a new speedster even if it's a
twist on a speedster like eobard thawne
had the big Harrison wells twist they're
still relatively true to their comic
book origin story so again I I know
there's a couple trailers we haven't got
yet we haven't got our Super Girl Season
2 Superman trailer yet we're due for
another flash and arrow trailer and of
the week or two there's going to be a
whole bunch of trailers dropping in
October for the movies too and there is
a rumor that we will get like the first
big big Justice League trailer this
Christmas so merry Christmas to everyone
even if you don't celebrate it but got a
whole bunch more comic book stuff
happening this week lots more Marvel DC
if you guys have any other requests for
bonus vid
is just let me know in the comments
below but just a reminder i started a
new round of the giveaway in that
Justice League teaser this morning all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card so get hype for flash season 3
i'm so excited i cannot wait for all
this stuff to come back well you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for that fat man Deathstroke
teaser from this morning and you can
click here for my thor ragnarok funny
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
Oh